[Music]
thank you
njrr tolkien's essay on fairy stories he
tells us that one of the functions of
those particular sorts of narratives and
this would also include not just fairy
stories but other kinds of fantasy and
some science fiction is that of escape
and it's not the kind of Escape ISM that
critics tend to reject in favor of
confronting real life or you know
standing up to your duties or things
like that Tolkien thinks that escape is
something quite legitimate and that we
have to have space for it and he's going
to talk about not just Escape or escapes
plural but also about human desires some
of them quite as he calls them earlier
in the essay primordial meaning that
they are there from the very beginning
in US human beings even down to the late
modern period that he's not quite so
sanguine about and so I think it could
be quite helpful for us to think about
Escape in terms of two interconnected
categories because it's not always so
simple as just one or the other
sometimes they're connected with each
other so escape from
but also Escape towards so that there's
not just a negation a trying to get away
from something but also escaping into
escaping towards escaping seeking
something that it is that we desire and
so he talks first about the escaping
from and there's really three main
categories that he's going to bring up
in this essay
so he talks about the rawness and
ugliness of modern European life he's
actually quoting this from Christopher
Dawson progress and religion and he says
that this is you know this according to
that the real life whose contact we
should welcome is the sign of a
biological inferiority an insufficient
or false reaction to the environment and
there is a lot of ugliness and rawness
in Modern Life sometimes deliberately so
you know think about the
brutalism in architecture we're going to
shove this in your face and he talks
about a whole bunch of other examples as
well that we don't necessarily need to
go through
but the key thing here is that there's
something repelling us about this he
talks about the
ugliness involved and he talks about the
improved means to deteriorated ends so
that's something that he thinks that we
we want to try to escape from quite
naturally and he gives uh examples of
this noise stench ruthlessness the
extravagance of the internal combustion
engine now you know maybe we take that
for granted and we're not so offended by
the existence of cars and motorcycles
and buses and stuff like that like
somebody from tolkien's time but there's
there's other things that we could bring
up that are similar to that as well and
then he says that there's there's a
second set of things when uh there are
Hunger thirst poverty pain sorrow
Injustice death and he called these hard
things right things that we wind up
facing now not everybody necessarily
experiences hunger and thirst as
conditions of your their life but if you
have well you would want to escape from
that you know poverty another prime
example you can be poor in a rich
society and that's not going to be great
pain you know some people live in
chronic pain every single day of their
life sorrow can come over so many things
including the hunger thirst poverty pain
and other bad things that other people
suffer seeing that the spectacle of it
can make you feel sorrow but you can
there's plenty of scope for sorrow in
your life as well Injustice
so much of that around now these of
course are not unique to Modern Life as
a matter of fact they exist everywhere
throughout time and not just for us but
in the case of you know some of these
hunger thirst pain sorrow exist for
Animals as well who you know
are made to suffer because of them so
that's something else that we want to
escape from and sometimes like he says
fairy tales can offer a type of that and
then finally he talks about death
fairy stories he says provide many
examples and modes of this which I might
which might be called the genuine
Escapist or fugitive spirit it's
interesting though because he doesn't
just talk about escaping from death
he also talks about escaping from
deathlessness
and he says that the human stories of
the elves are doubtlessful of the escape
from this
and a few lessons are taught more
clearly in these stories than the burden
of that kind of immortality or rather
endless serial living to which The
Fugitive would fly so death something we
want to avoid but a kind of living death
of just serial living perhaps another
thing that we want to avoid so escaping
from you know all of these are are
important they can play a role in the
plots of fairy stories but they're also
something motivating us to find Solace
consolation in those as well but then
it's not just a matter of running away
of fleeing all right there's also
escaping towards and he talks about
desires and the first one that
corresponds to this rawness and ugliness
of Modern Life is one for the beauty and
goodness of the human maid
things that are artifacts and you know
this this is quite interesting he tells
us that um
uh
uh here we go to us evil and ugliness
seem indissolibly uh Allied we find it
difficult to conceive of evil and Beauty
together the fear of the beautiful Fae
that ran through the Elder ages almost
eludes our grasp even more alarming
goodness is itself bereft of its proper
Beauty
in fairy one could indeed conceive of an
ogre who possesses a castle hideous as a
nightmare for the evil of the ogre Wills
itself but one cannot conceive of a
house built with a good purpose and in a
hostel for travelers the Hall of a
virtuous and Noble King that is yet
sickeningly
ugly
at the present day it would be rash to
hope to see one that was not unless it
was built before our time
and so he talks about this escapism uh
you know going back to a time when human
beings were as a rule delighted with the
work of their hands into our time when
many people feel discussed with man-made
things because of the ugliness we want
Beauty and goodness
we want haleness you could say health
wholeness again
another desire that we have is for
overcoming what he calls ancient
limitations and this can take several
different forms
one of these he says is a pardon
pardonable weakness or curiosity the
desire to visit free is a fish the deep
sea or the longing for the noiseless
gracious economical flight of a bird
that long in which the airplane cheats
except in rare moments seeing high and
by wind and distance noiseless turning
in the Sun that is precisely when
imagined and not used so we have this
desire to travel to all sorts of places
that are just not accessible for us and
for some of us this could be not quite
so far as the air the depths of the sea
you know it could be a matter of that
land over there that we just can't
access
but then he says there's others as well
he tells us there are profounder wishes
such as the desire to converse with
other living things now we converse with
other living things and we talk with
fellow humans don't we and if we have
pets or other animals that we're engaged
in we kind of talk to them we shatter a
lot we don't really know what they're
saying back to us
what if we could actually converse with
them
what if that was a possibility
he says on this desire as ancient as the
fall is largely found in the talking of
beasts and creatures and fairy tales and
especially the magical understanding of
their proper speech this is the root
Tolkien claims and not the confusion
attributed to the minds of men of the
unrecorded past and alleged absence of
the sense of separation of ourselves
from the Beast a vivid sense of that
separation is very ancient but also a
sense
that it is a severance
that there's something lacking something
lost something a privation that has
taken place he says a strange fate and a
guilt lies upon us other creatures are
like other Realms with which man has
broken off relations and sees now only
from the outside at a distance being at
war with them or on the terms of an
uneasy armistice
right and he says even about frogs you
know the creature that we often kind of
despise and in fairy tales are not
particularly
um you know well looked upon and he says
that it's a little Avail to consider
totemism whatever Customs or beliefs
about frogs and Wells lie behind the
stories the Frog shape was and is
preserved in the fairy story precisely
because it was so queer in the marriage
between a frog and a princess absurd
even abominable right the point of the
story lies not in thinking frogs
possible mates but in the necessity of
keeping promises that together with
observing prohibitions runs throughout
all of fairy land so this is an integral
part of that desire as well and then he
talks returning to the death thing the
oldest and deepest desire that we have
is The Great Escape the escape from
Death this is something that we are
looking for as well so the escapes that
that are involved in fairy tales are not
just escapes away from they're also
attempts to escape back towards into
something that we deeply desire and
that's why these stories when they're
well crafted really reach into our very
hearts and help us to deal with for
example sorrow or ugliness or having to
confront death all of these Tolkien
things are legitimate motives that run
throughout the crafting and also the
appreciation and enjoyment of fairy
stories